[Music]
a lot of people ask how I got into
donating to various causes and how I got
involved in even homelessness along the
way and popped out of it well it's a
very interesting story my mom asked what
to do with it at six years old we didn't
have any money there was my mother my
brother and I we had a deadbeat dad left
us before we were two but she took us at
Christmastime to downtown Los Angeles we
had little cars going around in circles
is pretty cool anyway some decorations
in the window she gave my brother and I
had time until his boys hold half of it
each give to the man ringing the bell in
the bucket we put in this bucket we said
mom why we give that man a dime that's
like two soda pops this is 1951 two soda
pops free candy bars and mom said boys
that's the Salvation Army now they take
care of people and have no place to live
and no food and we don't have a lot of
money but we could afford a dime this
year boys always remember in life give a
little something those in need to always
be somebody that's not as well off as
you are no matter where you are how far
down you are trying out sewing along the
way it stuck with me first time I was
homeless was two and a half oh my god
they don't work first of all I was
homeless I was twenty two and a half
years old and I had a two and a half
year old son I was working as the master
of ceremonies at the second annual
sports vacation recreational vehicle
show and had a check coming in at the
end of the week well I came home and I
drove her a one-car up to where we lived
and as I was getting out of the car and
going up towards our apartment door my
wife we very young by we got married at
20 and 19 years old my wife was coming
down the stairs and she said when the
story she took the keys by the time I
got through the door I saw my little boy
two and a half years old kind of just
sitting on top of a pile of clothes with
a note that basically said I can't
handle being a mom anymore he'll be much
better off with you
good luck now what I didn't know also
was that she had planned this for a few
months she had not paid the rent for a
few months and kept the money and I
didn't know that she wiped out what
little we had the savings account in the
bank and took the only car we had so
unbeknownst to me two days later I was
completely invented power shut off the
landlord she just right time this one
and I had this little kitten with me two
and a half years old and nine to be mom
and dad and that was really a bummer I
had no car so I ended up borrowing a
1951 Cadillac with a broken water-pump
from someone that was very very dear
have put water in it every four hours
and that's kind of how we got going
second time I was homeless is when I
started John Paul Mitchell Systems I
knew I needed half a million dollars to
start John Paul Mitchell Systems had to
have that so we had the backer lined up
I had a good job at the time than a nice
house and I left everything I had
because half a million dollars is coming
down the street I was insardi company so
I left it all behind I left what money I
had with my wife we were getting along
well at all and the best car and I took
the older car was a good one but an
older car ran good down the hill to get
my money I would check into an
efficiency hotel and then cuz I'd be
traveling a lot and eventually in an
apartment when I went down the hill the
backer pulled out no money well it was
later that afternoon that a friend of
mine found me said John Paul please call
dick Holthaus direct collect in England
he doesn't have the best news for you so
I got ahold of vamper in the wee hours
the morning and he said JP the backer
pulled out the reason he pulled out was
inflation in the United States was
twelve and a half percent unemployment
ten percent actually over ten percent
interest rates if you could get a loan
prime rate was seventeen percent
interest and we still had hostages that
I ran and we waited in line for gasoline
that was the environment the United
States in 1980 and 1981 well there I was
a few hundred dollars my pocket too
proud to ask my mother if I could have
my old room back from my home and she
could feed me for a couple months I get
back on my feet and I just left my
living situation I was too proud stupid
but very very proud so I went by and saw
my mom and uh you know I was bought a
couple hundred dollars from her I said
mom will give it back to you she said
son you're doing really well in life why
didn't a few hundred dollars a month
I'll give it back to him I'm starting
something new and that's why I decided
I'm going to make it I'm not going to
tell her
lived in my car shower down to Griffith
Park they had tennis courts there were
showers in in and or not live off very
little and go ahead and sell products
door-to-door when I was homeless on my
mind was not oh my god how did I get
here who's to blame on this what was in
my mind was okay after I cried a little
in the two and a half year old son not
knowing what to do no money no nothing
my first thought was okay I need to get
some money and I want to go to my mom's
house and tell her how bad things are I
need to get money to eat and what we're
sources of money we don't have any money
so I went around collecting soda pop
bottles from empty lots and at that time
a grocery store or any liquor store
would give you two cents for little one
five cents for a big one
one round collected a lot of them cash
in that's how we got the money and so we
were able to eat now when I got evicted
out of the house a three days later this
is when I was 22 and a half years old
when I was completely evicted now we had
that car I borrowed to live in and we
went more towards fast foods that were
halfway prepared for you those are the
early days of fast food just to eat a
few days later a friend of mine found
makes he knew I was hanging out talked
to some friends of mine named Lee Myer
and Lee said Johnny I've got a house
with an extra room use a biker a real
heavy-duty biker and he says you and
your son can live here to get on your
feet
no problem we could have some of the
biker mamas take care of your son while
you're working and let's move on we're
buddies and those are they helping him I
think whether you have money or don't
have money it's very important to give
back because it's we the people
individuals that make the planet better
so that this doesn't happen again it
makes it better for other people it's we
to people if we don't help others out
and people start going down then what do
we expect as future customers your
future people helps us out if we were in
trouble so I feel that every human being
has the obligation paying a little bit
of red for being on this planet to do
something good for their city or their
state or their country or even the world
to make it a better place to live now if
you don't have any money okay
you could volunteer like I don't have
any money at Thanksgiving Christmas of a
Griffith Park in California helping feed
the homeless or do something help
somebody else out to make the world a
better place to live no benefits buy
this whenever you do something for
somebody else and ask them absolutely
nothing in return you get the greatest
hide you could ever have in your life
and it makes you more connected with the
whole planet a lot of people think they
have to give huge amount of money to
make the impact well I would disagree
with them because I remember back my mom
we had almost nothing knew the
importance of giving two little boys a
dime to put in the bucket because she
knows times became many dimes many
dollars and many $10 bills but every
little bit gives back every little bit
so no matter how little you give or a
little of your time you donate you've
done a little something that little
something makes a difference
[Music]